Caseless reasoning has a very strong connection with human cognition as well.
Analogical reasoning in general is considered to be a core process of cognition.
But analogical reasoning depends upon a spectrum of similarity. At oned
end of this spectrum are problems which are identical to previously encountered
problems. In that case, we simply have to retrieve the previous solution and
apply it. At the other end of the spectrum, are problems with just
semantically very dissimilar from previously encountered problems. We'll discuss
those problems later in the class. In the middle of the spectrum are problems.
Which are similar, but not identical, to previously encountered parts. So now,
we need to retrieve the past solutions, tweak them, and apply them.
It is this middle of the spectrum, which is most common in human cognition.
Again, going back over cognitive architecture, which had 3 components.
Reasoning, learning, and memory. Learning by recording cases shifted
the balance from reasoning to learning and memory. Case we can contrast unifies
the three of them. It says learning is important because we need to acquire and
store experiences. Memory is important because we need to be able to retrieve
those experiences when needed. And reasoning is important because we need to
be able to tweak those experiences to encounter the needs of new problems.